[Music]
joining me now is Van Gan who resigned
from upenn's Board of Trustees back in
October van um why did you
resign well you know Laura I
um I served since
2009 and over that period of time I
found that at every turn the board was
just a rubber stamp to the chairman of
the board and that they really never
disagreed that every vote was unanimous
and when it came to this
controversy um I was appalled by the
lack of response by the president of the
university and you know sought to have
my fellow board members speak up uh
along with me and say something that um
would put her in a position to have to
um change her views and and do
something I was told by my board
members to stay on the board and wait
for an emergency meeting that was called
which I did and I found that at that
meeting it was just the same old same
old so I quit um on the basis that if I
stayed I would be under a fiduciary
responsibility to not disclose what went
on at the board and as an outside person
I can now speak out against the uh
horrible things that have been going on
at the University and to call for the
resignation of the board president and
chair do you agree with Bill Amman that
these presidents who testified on
Capitol Hill yesterday who couldn't
answer simple questions at utter distain
for the the Congressional inquiry um
couldn't ask answer simple questions
should they
resign well I can tell you this Laura
that there is no no context in which
the you know the genocide of the Jewish
people can be condoned it's nothing more
than harassment and hateful and
malicious uh talk and you know it cannot
be condoned unlike with the the position
of the University presidents and it's
certainly not conducive to learning for
the poor students who you know attend
colleges and universities um that were
displayed in Congress
yesterday well kids are waiting to here
now who applied to colleges yeah yeah
sorry we have a delay here but let me
let me let me just let me sorry let me
just kids are waiting to hear right now
who applied early from a lot of these
schools um whether they've been admitted
or not early and I think there's a lot
of angst out there among kids like oh am
I going to get into these schools what
do you say to them about the the the
process given what's happening on campus
now where should they be putting their
focus on the places as they go or what
they do once they're
there well to be patently honest with
you you know as I had indicated before
to bolster that point the
Anti-Defamation League did a study and
they can and in the study of the Jewish
students who an American colleges they
concluded that more than half don't feel
safe on their college or university
campus and 75% of those kids feel that
they have been involved in or have w
witnessed an act of anti-Semitism so if
you're the parent of a Jewish student in
the 9th 10th or 11th
grade you certainly wouldn't want to
send your kid to any one of those
universities and Van what do you say to
the board members of these universities
MIT Harvard upen
NYU um that are again they're they're
rubber stamping whatever the
administration is doing there's very few
voices of of Courage yours was one um in
these board scenarios what do you say to
them
today it's time to step up and be
counted and not just serve on these
boards to just have a prestigious thing
to put on your resume or so that you can
tell your friends that I'm on the board
of Harvard or Penn or whatever it's time
to actually be a working trustee and to
speak up when things aren't right and
not rubber stamp you know what goes on
just because the chairman of the board
says it's the thing to do or the
President says it's the thing to do in
your heart if you know it's wrong you
need to step up and say that it's the
wrong thing well I note that you're an
entrepreneur and entrepreneurs tend to
have a lot more courage than corporate
CEOs V thank you so much for speaking
out I hope to talk with you again soon
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
any anywhere
else